[Musique]
bonsoir petit ami j'espère que vous
n'avez pas la rougeole comme notre ami
cornichons pas trop je suis persuadé
qu'il va mieux ce soir et je lui apporte
quelques friandises et quelques fleurs
ma petite échelle et au
pop auto
promo
[Musique]
bonsoir mais au fond ça nous bonsoir
amis mais cornichons et le vus eh oui
chers nounours notre malade est presque
guérie nos siro ont fait merveille oui
mais j'aimerais bien sorti quel petit
malade un patient fait voir la figure
elle ne presque plus
rouler voyons là plus de fièvre
je crois que demain tu pourra sortir si
le temps est beau mais en attendant
jetez apporter quelques friandises
là ces petits paquets sont pour
cornichons julietta ne fais pas ta
coquine
du gâteau j'y vais bientôt
j'ai pas faim alors une belle mandarine
mon petit corner son ouïe
vit alors un peu de crème à la vanille
au nom nous
j'ai vraiment pas faim on va bien côté
un peu de ces bonnes choses pepita fema
voir cette crème à la vanille mon pauvre
petit cornichons cette vilaine rougeole
da ôter tout olympique va vite te
coucher il ne faut pas que tu reste trop
longtemps debout je veux bien nous je me
sens fatigué et ne fait pas d'efforts
inutiles
ça fait du bien de retrouver son bon
dodo on dort toi vite effet de boer
heures oui de boer est
tout à coup la
tuerait que même des mal et c'est un
petit peu de calme pépite a du talent ne
fait pas tant de bruit quand ni chantage
que se passe-t-il il a neigé toute la
crème à la vanille ouais et pepita à
manger tous les biscuits vous êtes
gourmand
pepita il est l'heure de rentrer chez
toi nous partons ensemble au revoir d'un
an bonsoir mes amis
[Musique]
oh
pas trop bonne nouvelle corniche on va
beaucoup mieux ça te fait plaisir lenovo
oui je t'ai un tueur mois et bien en
route
bonnut les enfants embrasser bien fort
vos parents n'oubliez pas de faire votre
toilette l'avez-vous ledent
si vous êtes malade
laissez-vous bien soigné défaites pour 1
[Musique]
et